I get it bingi center-right bro Mo Money
mo problems
[Music]
what up vlog nothing you'll call just
want to show you babban you know just
want to show everybody the man behind
the rocks success if the categories look
at a different way they're gonna get
this proportionate opportunity there's
some insane data that is in their favor
because of who actually has and because
I've been spending the last year and a
half with the CEO that's leading to our
big opportunity over here i
disproportionally know about the fact
that a lot of ways are really really
good when you start figuring out the
impact of how much wasted and its impact
on the environment like it's it's
stunning how good is for the world but
there's no millennial mom that would
believe that I think Eric will probably
bring a little more detail and nuance to
this but that's the task at hand and we
have a big appetite and a big
opportunity and I think they'll call my
bluff after we come with it to let us
execute the influencer and Facebook
video work that I think can actually
achieve the success that's why excited
that's why we're on this call got it
40 40
this game industry this came in
yesterday Deeley uh I've really really
really bad news you bought the wrong
Jersey that's not his number anymore
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious you know
it's funny your Russian accent got
heavier just now when the stress came
out does that happen I don't know that
was so [ __ ] cool I just heard your
Russian accent we need to get a new one
faster now you've got real work to do
because it's Friday start hustling her
start hustling yeah this the kids at
home when you get me a Jersey and your
name is Len you've got a really hustle
when the numbers wrong my man Dee Lee is
now number 58 this is last year's Jersey
you got 48 hours my man fix it okay so I
so [ __ ] up here he asked me to order
from the judge Jersey there you eat so
what I did I went online saw the first
Jersey that was daring these ordered it
it comes in
what do I do now it's currently 216 p.m.
right now on Friday the game is on
Sunday at 1:00 p.m. I have 47 hours
[Music]
and you need to find this Jersey hello
hi how are you that's good
hi guys doing good awesome how's it
going so far
good you guys awake we get here Google
itself is a toll booth for all of us and
then the smart people built companies on
top of Google to be another toll booth
on top of the Google toll booths so like
the reason I use that is I don't think
people a lot of people if they don't
understand it or even if you're in it
and been doing it for years I think
sometimes we don't think of it enough as
toll booths like these are Google's a
toll booth then all the leaders and your
businesses that are referral sites and
affiliate sites are the next toll booth
and they were just better at getting in
front of somebody before you and the
reason I believe in brand so much stuff
that most of the people in this room
hate because it's not clocked it's not
black and white it's not I spent $4 and
I got $3 back okay let me [ __ ] with it
I spent $1 I get 13 dollars back holy
[ __ ] let me spend as much on it as I can
the reason everybody hates it is it's
not measurable but it's the reason
everybody's here and I'm sitting here
it's brand and so the risks you should
all be taking we'll get to it one by one
on brand is extraordinary because it
fixes everything else out ok so I'm in
the car this is my last chance my only
hope to find this Jersey I have 40 about
46 hours remaining till game time if not
today
hopefully tomorrow and then if not then
I just have one last thing to do and
that's go to the game by the Jersey
there and hopefully it'll be good if
they have it bro there's only one way
for to win a family business radical
candor and you know how easy that is in
a family business almost impossible so
I'm giving you advice that's hard
radical candor you're just gonna lose
it's gonna eat you inside and I've good
news for you this is the only chance to
have a good relationship with them not
the other way around you think you're
doing the right thing to have a good
relationship with them you're leading to
the things that's gonna make you have
Gretz and real issues with them and
you're gonna snap and you guys don't
have a bad relationship Oh
and you and you your [ __ ] five
seconds in second third generation
family business people pay the biggest
tax in the world and when they're
[ __ ] talented they really are [ __ ]
you know what family business dynamics
are good for losers that's when you're
lucky when you suck [ __ ] and you're the
one benefiting you know when family
businesses suck when you're a winner and
you're paying a tax nobody's ever paid
in life guys have built a business from
three to sixty million dollars and left
at 34 years old with $100,000 in my bank
account because I was making myself
forty fifty sixty thousand dollars and
zero equity on paper to buy mortgage for
me and my wife because I own zero
percent of Wine Library how [ __ ]
lucky am i trolls on YouTube latest
update it's almost four o'clock in the
car driving there's a little bit of
traffic so you know what's happening
with all the ad agencies creative shops
why they're dead they started with art
and they hate numbers cuz arts a lot
more fun because nobody can keep score
so you just will yourself to victory
through headlines awards and being
louder you're in a great spot when you
bring an r/t you know Rick or Sally
you're gonna hold them somewhat more
accountable while we're let me give you
a good piece of ice do it bring in
somebody who's above the line meet
creative whatever give them a budget and
don't scrutinize him what the three
uncles [ __ ] up with him is they should
have just given him it and gotten the
[ __ ] out if you're gonna bring in
somebody to do creative or or be an
editor in chief depending how extreme
you go this for a lot of you just let
just say Sally $800,000 do you make one
KPI the subjective column the two of you
that it actually brought value at the
end of one year
Kim will tell you the way I manage I'm
like I'm not in it but I'll look at it
at the macro because that's how I've won
I've always won cuz I do [ __ ] that makes
no mathematical sense upfront until it
does
got it so you and by the way give me
another good piece of ice give that
person the amount of money that you're
most comfortable with going 2-0 and then
I've got the best part for you get 20%
better at what you do so that it's a net
equal if you're gonna give this person
100,000 make your five hundred thousand
work like six hundred thousand and
twenty eighteen cuz you guys can get
better that's how you got it it's fun
you'll get better at your part which is
just smart that frees up two hundred cuz
now five hundred thousand is being is
working as if it's six hundred cuz
you're trying harder and you get the
taste [ __ ] that's the way you build a
business guys thank you so much awesome
thank you thanks for coming a couple
meetings now can't film them and
wrapping up and heading home for some
family time
I hope babban find something funny let's
see if Lev can get me the Jersey I'm
looking for so it's Saturday morning you
just woke up about it go pick up this
Jersey in a couple of hours it's time to
get ready and I'll see you next week a
lot of hustle a lot of New York time see
ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]